[Music]
in London did you hear this this is a
cool story in London athletes at the
Olympics are being issued 15 condoms
each yeah so now every athletes dream is
to return home with a gold medal and no
condoms I got a gold medal and I still
have my 15 condoms
speaking of Olympic sex that's my
favorite transition in a while pretty
good i meddled in that one bronze
that's still pretty good third in the
world not in the world in my house is
peachy
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what the hell now you've changed your
flag all right you grew ashamed of your
country that quickly
speaking of Olympic sex an Olympic
sharpshooter check this out an Olympic
sharpshooter from Malaysia is going to
be eight months pregnant when she
competes in her event they're crazy
Yeti sharpshooters first target will be
the bastard who knocked her up little
bit of controversy for MIT Romney it's
being reported that when MIT Romney
spoke at the n-double-a-cp last week he
may have brought as many as 200 of his
own african-american supporters because
nothing shows your commitment to civil
rights like saying I've shipped in my
own black people
[Applause]
I see you're all here we could begin
also some controversy for the Democrats
the Democrats have apologized for using
Mitt Romney's horse in an ad yeah still
you gotta love an ad that ends with I'm
Mitt Romney's horse and I approve this
message
that wasn't a horse that was a ghost I
just did
horsey enough was horsey enough it's not
more like a ghost to me
Oh get you the it's a goofy ghost the
United States Postal Service is about to
default on a five point five billion
dollar payment yeah the post office
claims they made the payment but the
check got lost in the mail
[Applause]
[Music]
any Burger King fans here okay do they
run our ads on our show hey let's hear
it for Burger King
I love all fast food monarchies well a
group of Burger King employees have been
fired for taking a photo of themselves
with their feet in the restaurants
lettuce yeah yeah spokesmen from Burger
King said great there goes our secret
recipe still god I love Burger King now
[Applause]
Isis interesting has been reported that
Modern Family's Sofia Vergara is now the
highest-paid woman on television - yeah
yet sadly she still can't afford shirts
that fit
it's really tragic see those breasts all
the time hey check this one out that's
code for I like this one according to a
professor at Stanford playing video
games and watching porn will lead to the
demise of the male species now isn't
that amazing I had no idea my mother was
a professor at Stanford
[Applause]
you